one more time let's go Wow here aren't
you how if you don't know about me
pounds there are some a quickly well
yeah I'm pal you know
oh alright
good size yeah this is an excellent sign
yes so um today some of my songs right
I'm gonna help you okay so uh no
pressure okay so the first one we're
gonna do is called celebrate celebrate
celebrate okay it goes anywhere what go
gang rollin what
anywhere I go gang rolling what does
that mean that means anywhere I go my
friends are coming with me
yeah anywhere I go gang rolling yes
that's perfect
then it says Motley's got the loud
pattern oh now stop it and then I'll say
man demamp rien that which one then I
want you to say big big baggy on the
Left big baddie battery Oh Betty
big big battery on the left yeah you try
it okay alright DJ let's go
since it all intro it's kind of like you
know a little dance on boogie hey get
ready for that big moment three one two
three in the celebration okay okay it
goes i remixed a shitty so little be
involved okay so it says pow yeah i'm
due to the d pal if you don't know about
me
pow they out summer quickly cuz pal yeah
i'm pal you know pal how's that have you
got a fortnight haha all right we good
the roman DJ
[Music]
within the first 5 1 2 3 Wow don't know
about me Wow they'll also look with me
wow yeah wow yeah Omni Wow if you don't
know about me Wow
they are awesome of 15 now one more time
let's go Wow yeah Wow you don't know
about yeah you know due to the deed I'm
gonna school you didn't know